patrice carmouze bonjourbonjour ironique
merci d'être mon invité oui c'est
bizarre mais bon tout visa j'espère que
ça va aller pour la position qu'il
préfère c'est vrai on va falloir faire
un effort pendant 13 minutes on est au
pied de téléphiles à saint quentin là où
nos officiers absolue à eux et moi j'ai
envie de faire mieux connaissance avec
vous parce que tout le monde vous
connaît et en fait on ne sait pas grand
chose est ce qu'il y aurait moyen de
remonter un petit peu dans le temps
d'évoquer matthieu reeb on peut oui
c'est vrai ça commençait donc cette
carrière la matière et
audiovisuelle non moins qu'à three year
commencé d'abord dans le stade du mans
prof de quoi l'histoire du droit et
voilà où ça
à nanterre et puis
et puis et puis non et puis j'ai
commencé dans le journalisme écrit
vraiment non je te suit après en fait on
alors journalisme mais passionné donc
oui oui oui je faisais ça pour autant
que des études quoi mais non j'avais
envie de faire du journalisme notamment
aujourd'hui politique et donc j'ai écrit
comme ça trois journaux enfin quelques
jours j'ai eu la chance de rentrer au
quotidien de paris voilà de philippe
tesson qui a fermé le lendemain du jour
où j'ai été engagé à un signe qui est un
signe et donc je veux dire quoi là
qu'ils veulent et dire que très
gentiment marc près au quotidien du
médecin qui était qui était un mari
claude tesson qui était dans la famille
tes swing et donc je suis resté j'ai
commencé là pendant pendant quelques
années j'aurais dit tu sais le service
lui révèle chef et puis et puis le
quotidien de paris a reparu et donc
après je suis reparti obliger à
travailler voilà je retrouve ma place où
j'étais j'ai dû diriger le service
société du service politique puis
service id et j'avais aucune intention
de faire de télévision
et c'était ça qui m'intéressait et puis
se trouve que je connaissais un certain
christophe dechavanne et qui faisait des
émissions l'après-midi alors il m'a
demandé de venir faire une chronique
l'après-midi
et puissantes émissions ont été
supprimées cette émission c'était
c'était panique sur le seuil du passé
l'après midi passé l'après-midi les
vannes avaient fait d'abord une autre
émission c'est encore mieux l'après midi
à présent non
c'est pas dit qu sur le site est à peu
près la même émission sur tf1 qui s'est
arrêté au bout d'un moment
peut-être à cause de bois non je crois
pas
et donc qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait faire on encore réfléchi c'est
comme ça qu'est née ciel mon mardi et
vous avez gardé cette idée de binômes de
travailler ensemble alors porte du bus
début j'étais plutôt moi je restais dans
la presse écrite et s est infligé machin
voit la réunion et puis j'étais au bloc
note quand même et puis au bout d'un an
voilà on a fait quelques scoops quand
même on avait des gens que tout le monde
recherchés et c'est qu'on a vu avait eu
way et donnez moi des émissions a
beaucoup aimé ça n'est pas bleu rien à
personne par exemple il y avait un type
qui s'appelait le baron noir alors le
baron noir et est un type qui survolait
paris et tous les journaux franchement à
l'époque c'était ça faisait la une de
tous les jeunes mais parce que c'est
interdit bidons de lait par est passé
au-dessus de la tour eiffel était passé
sous l'arc de triomphe la nuit donc tout
chercher le ballon doit il se trouve que
j'ai réussi à le trouver beaucoup mieux
il a annoncé sa non c'est un peu ce
qu'il y avait donc au bout d'un an
christophe a demandé de venir m'en
occuper je me suis dit juillet les trois
mois
invités s'étaient pas les amis c'est mon
mardi c'était beaucoup de débats oui
donc c'était l'étape des débats elle m
comment ça allait un peu frites est
dedans bref alors après tout ça après
tout ça on en est où on en a fait
beaucoup après on a fait une émission
qui s'appelait comme l'indiqué se
passait nous sommes dans un décor
c'était l'homme métro ne sais pas
pourquoi ça traîne toujours avec
christophe alors moi je n'étais plus
l'antenne je m'étais du journal non j'ai
donc il était à l'oreillette alors
jurent les résultats de mon dieu j'ai
insulté tout le monde
l'aurait et puis après je suis parti
sur paris première pour faire une
émission qui s'appelait rive droite rive
gauche avec thierry ardisson d'accord on
enceinte rossi donc au raid accepte
toujours were avec ce faux producteurs
ok vous étiez à l'écran et j'étais à
l'écran et on était à l'écran on était
une bande y avait il frédéric beigbeder
y avait philippe tesson que fait revenir
y avait dix à quinze mois alors d'accord
les premières hockey est alors plus plus
récemment refusé louis plus récemment
merci comment est venue tvfi là qu'est
ce que vous faites alors tv fils est
venu parce que je me suis occupé pendant
quelques années puis pour avancer une
ktm c'est une chaîne qui s'applique
cap24 que sur la tnt régionale et qui
est une semaine et qui était vachement
bien mais qu aider on avait des
actionnaires
qui était très bon mais qui nous ont
vendu à une sorte d' escroc et là tu
peux rien payer au bout d'un moment et
donc la vérité et c'est comme ça que
j'ai rencontré tient la vedette qui
était directeur de tv fils qui
tournèrent qu'il est toujours il n'a pas
été viré plus et non qui s'était dit
mais c'est pourquoi on ferait pas une
proposition de rachat de cette chaîne ça
qu'on s'est connus la proposition n'a
pas au bout tu parce que on n'a pas eu
assez de temps pour la mettre en oeuvre
et c'est là qu'il va proposer de devenir
travailler à tv fils et moi ça me
passionnait parce que justement j'avais
de quelques passionnés d'un set j'avais
déjà le jeu régional je crois que la
télé nationale moi je les laisse
un peu je crois que c'est fini
maintenant je crois que c'est on va
passer à tron voit bien avec l'arrivée
de netflix des choses comme ça c'est la
fin quand on faisait ciel mon mardi
c'est vrai que les gens le mercredi ils
avaient tous regardé ça il parlait de ça
au bistrot c'est plus le cas aujourd'hui
plus des mises à part les grands rendez
vous sportifs en gros voilà qui est
vraiment de soins n'ont
alors rien solutions du marché mais je
pense que c'est la fin en revanche qu'il
pense qu'il ya un avenir formidable sur
les sur les chaînes de proximité dire
que à condition que cette barrière qui
est parce que la télévision c'est quand
même rester encore pour les gens qui
fait rêver tout ça en réalité cela sinon
seraient pas l'armée réalité c'est
quelque chose dont les gens devraient
s'emparer et je pense que dans les
chaînes locales ou départementales comme
tu es comme tv fils ça pourrait devenir
été un élément de la démocratie un
élément du débat un élément de à
condition qu'ils sont part de ses
chaînes c'est un peu le cas la
précédente il avait énormément invités
locaux absolument qui viennent parler de
leur quotidien alors
qu'il faudrait mais ça ce fut un peu
dans la dans la nouvelle grille de tv
fils c'est l'idée c'est que c'est
d'aller au beau milieu des gens c'est
que les gens puissent puisse intervenir
même se retrouver c'est qu'ils ont face
au fond leur leurs outils de
communication et leur outil parce que
voilà on va aller dans un monde un peu
compliqué de plus en plus mondialisé
dont tu vois là mais on a besoin aussi
de se retrouver parce que on se sent
plus proche de voilà de l'onu on habite
on a envie d'être à venir on a envie de
dire des choses donc je pense que il ya
un véritable autant je pense que c'est
la télévision nationale on est à un
changement de période de temps chaud
mais je pense qu'il ya vrai avenir pour
les avions le gall après avec le
problème des moyens évidemment question
d'accord donc actuellement vous êtes
vous avez quel poste tv fil 78 soit peu
conseillé de deux téléfilms ou alors
d'accord parallèlement aux vip et
parallèlement la veille avec une
certaine véronique qui thuribe un rib
d'accord gentiment vous lui avez le
synpics
alors moi je vais dire que elle elle est
très bien on a eu beaucoup tout avoué
des personnalités bien fait la preuve à
moi je vais interview plutôt les
monuments cette année vous allez faire
parler la pierre mais quand et je reste
un beau défi mais j'avais envie de faire
quelque chose un peu ce nom de faire
redécouvrir le patrimoine de 2 des
yvelines est plein et oui beaucoup de
choses y a pas que sur d'autres
versailles oui si vous le lancez vrai
nom hockey et vous travaillez aussi sur
rtl pour terminer mais aussi sur
une émission qui s'appelle à la bonne
heure avec
je suis rédacteur un accès temporaire de
chef dans le truc dans ma vie
ouais chef c'est pourquoi j'ai pas aimé
c'est pas moi qui ai voulu moi j'aurais
préféré voir projeté dans la presse
écrite j'aurais préféré être
porteur partir massa non me dit toi tu
restes tu diriges la tête pensante
ensuite donc on va parler un peu de
notre chaîne de chéri un tvt oui et des
nouveautés ce qui paraît à oui il ya des
malades justement c'est de cette idée
encore une fois dans fait de faire en
sorte que les gens sont par un peu de
cette chaîne il ya le café politique
alors est ce que c'est café politique
c'est un rendez-vous keep tous les
quinze jours qui se faire au public qui
se fait dans un match qui va venir
absolument qu'ils se barrent théâtre
saint quentin en yvelines et on reçoit
seville fried qui présente l'émission et
récits effet fléchi et qui reçoit imbert
est donc ce fatal est amer certains
maires pourquoi pourquoi parce que
l'idée cette voie là que les gens
puissent venir interroger c'est
l'heureux c'est là où ils vivent ces
questions a demandé des comptes on peut
on peut lui dire pourquoi là pourquoi
vous avez feront poivre enfin des choses
très concrètes mais qui sont la vie de
tous les jours donc ça c'est une des
façons de gâchis politique ces cafés
politiques il ya un autre rendez-vous
mort est un peu moins bien qu'ils
avaient le vin le mec qui présentait pas
terrible ça pulse pas une att dira
peut-être dû virer
non c'est moi et
il a une certaine lundi que vers quoi
pas ça veut dire
alors ça c'est la nouvelle émission
d'obligations je me trompe pas c'est ça
alors là on aura un invité et puis il
demande une bande dont vous faites
partie voilà alors on appris seillier
des journaux disent mais
pharmacien il ya un restaurant ces gens
là société civile comme en vie
pas dit m
et l'idée c'est d'abord dans tout un tas
de sujets alors nationaux ou locaux et
on débat et puis on peut avoir aussi un
invité la première
la philosophe
parler d'éducation donc c'est un débat
ouvert tour d'un invité ou autour de
thèmes mais hélas aussi si les
téléspectateurs veulent venir de temps
en temps une poussée leurs coups de
gueule c'est avec un grand plaisir
d'accord moi je pense que le message est
passé et ensuite donc pour en revenir
aux nouveautés dans leur site internet
site internet totalement renouvelée oui
parce que ça c'est très important parce
que je crois l'inde est à venir de ces
chaînes aussi c'est l'internet quand je
pense que la consommation samedi à la
télévision c'est très bien mais c'est
compliqué avec les des serveurs il faut
changer de numéro parce qu'internet
aujourd'hui sur le site donc c'est très
important puisque là aussi c'est un peu
interviendra si c'est un tati voilà mai
puis nouveau logo voilà très bien que
c'est une chaîne qui vit ok bon on a
oublié parler de vos livres parce que
vous avez dit ouais ouais mais
ça serait l'occasion de revenir
et puis bon bah téléphiles cesser notre
chaîne c'est votre chaîne sachet de
visite minerait quoi absolument qui
viennent on va y revenir venir va nous
prendre notre place
bon ben voila merci merci beaucoup mais
à bientôt